i know you got to get going the lonesome
space cowboy remember that
last question that you couldn't get to
which was if the general public knew or
saw what you saw
how would they what would the next week
look like how would the public react
somber uh
i think there would be this uh
big exhale for about a day
and then this uh turning inward
and trying to reflect on what this means
to us and our species and ourselves
uh i think uh somber sorry
like a sigh of relief somber meaning
serious not not
like hollywood portrays people partying
in the streets and
silliness with that um i think you would
have
uh some people perhaps turning to
religion
more so uh you might have some people
turning away from those
um i think you're gonna have um
at that point the the philosophical and
theological
uh questions will be raised
and and people will have some serious
soul-searching to do no pun intended
and i don't think that's bad by the way
i think a lot of folks that have spent
their times in this community being
charlatans will have been exposed
and they will be probably unemployed and
probably have to change their names
because
you know the rest of society will look
at them
in an unfavorable light i think um
there are some unsung heroes that will
probably come to light
and uh the world will appreciate their
contributions to this topic
i think the scientific concerning
academic communities no i can't
i know what i was going to say is names
that have been announced before when you
say the unsung heroes or
new names haven't been announced before
okay uh
i think the scientific and academic
community is going to have to take a
real hard look at itself
uh and and see why it repeated the same
mistakes it did
when galileo first proposed that the
earth was not the center of the solar
system
uh you know hubris
is is is a big part of that um
and then i think you know maybe we start
the international conversation say okay
we realize that this
there's there's some things out there
that are probably well beyond our petty
discrepancies we have with each other
um maybe we really need to start working
together on this
realize that we are really a global
family it doesn't matter
where you're from it doesn't matter what
your religion is or
culture or your color or anything else
uh we are we are all uh we are all
brothers and sisters on this tiny little
rock caller
you know this pale blue dot that's
hurtling through space
um it may unify us
well i would certainly hope so
you